. Und ich mache das Fenster zu. Ich habe das letzte Mal gehört, dass in der Offenheim ganz viele sehr interessante Gespräche aus dem Gehsteig waren. Und ich immer hingerissen war, zu sagen so, Moment mal, Monika zieht aus der WG aus jetzt, Moment mal. Und das lenkt so so ein bisschen vom Podcast ab, deswegen mache ich es Fenster zu. Ja, auch diese Mopeds, die bei dir mal vorbeifahren, diese lauten Motorräder, das war immer viel zu laut. Ja, diese sizilianische Stimmung, diese Ragazzo-Stimmung, wo man einfach schön in der Westen... Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist Frankreich, nee. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO, DPU, herzlich willkommen mit Stefan Teizzi. Hey, ich bin auch wieder da. Und mit Florentin Will natürlich. Call from Stefan Teizzi. Stefan Teizzi. Call from Stefan Teizzi. Das ist wirklich wunderschön. Ich habe in meinen Kopfhörern immer so die Ansage, wenn mein iPhone angerufen wird. Und wirklich ist es so, wie kriegen wir eine KI hin, die den Namen möglichst falsch ausspricht? Das ist so ein bisschen wie diese Internet-Videos, wo dann so Schauspielnamen. Ralper Fiennes statt Ralph Fiennes möglichst falsch ausgesprochen werden. Ich glaube, dieser Gag hat seinen Ursprung in dieser Vorlesestimme von diesen iPhones. Call from Stepper Tetzetzze. Er ist wirklich lächerlich, aber ich weiß, wer gemeint ist. Ja, das stimmt. Weil ich erkenne den Tonfall. Diesen genervten, er schon wieder, dieser, ach, es ist schon wieder Stefan Teizy. Calling again, steppertazza. Siri ist auch schon langsam genervt, calling again. Ja, oder Siri hat den Running Gag mitbekommen, dass dein Name immer anders ausgesprochen wird. Jetzt macht sie auch mit. Vielleicht ist die KI so weit entwickelt, dass wir sie gar nicht mehr, dass wir sie als dumm wahrnehmen, dass wir zu dumm sind und denken, die KI sei dumm, dabei verstehen wir nur die Gags nicht. Ich finde, das Ralph Fiennes ist doch auch noch falsch, oder? Ja. Ich meine, klar, die Menschheit hat sich darauf geeinigt, irgendwann auf Ralph Fiennes, aber es sieht auch einfach anders aus. Geschrieben sieht Ralph Fiennes anders aus. Mach mal kurz einen Test. Schreibt mal, nehmt euch mal einen Stift oder zumindest
irgendwie Word oder sowas, ein anderes Textprogramm
und schreibt mal das Wort
Stiehlt. R, sie, es
Stiehlt die Show.
Es sieht falsch geschrieben aus.
Das Wort Stiehlt
sieht falsch aus.
Ohne I, E, ne? Nur mit I.
Ja, nur mit I, nur mit I, E, ohne H.
Es sieht immer falsch aus, aber es ist richtig S, T, i, e, h, l, t, stiehlt. Das spricht man auch so aus, stiehlt, wenn man es korrekt aussprechen möchte, ja. Das korrekte Deutsch ist, ja, schwierig zu sprechen. Wie geht's dir, Florentin, was erlebst du gerade so? Gut, gut, gut. Hey, erstmal ankommen in dieser Folge, heute ist es eine gechillte Folge. Das Problem ist ja, also zum Beispiel, also ich bleib noch kurz bei den Namen, weil... Bleib bei den Namen. Ich finde, und ich bin jemand, dessen Name sehr oft falsch ausgesprochen wird und generell falsch ausgesprochen wird. Das macht keinen Sinn, weil er gesprochen wird, wie er geschrieben wird. Ja, aber, naja, gut, es gibt ja noch so Betonungen. Das Problem ist, diese Angelegenheit, Namen falsch aussprechen, ist von vorne bis hinten verdorben. Weil zum Beispiel, es gibt ja noch so Betonungen. Das Problem ist, diese Angelegenheit Namen falsch aussprechen ist von vorne bis hinten verdorben, weil zum Beispiel es gibt ja Denzel Washington, der heißt Denzel Washington, der Mann, nicht Denzel. Der heißt Danz-el Washington, wie Samuel L. Jackson. Das Problem ist jetzt, manche Leute wissen das, manche nicht. Weniger Leute wissen, wie man ihn richtig ausspricht.
Jetzt weiss ich, wie man ihn richtig ausspricht. Trotzdem scheue ich mich davor, ihn richtig auszusprechen, weil ich möchte ja a nicht dann heißen, hey, den spricht man doch anders aus, und dann muss ich wieder in ... Nee, pass auf, Folgendes, bei Jimmy Kimmel hat er in Folge 722 bei Minute 18 die richtige Aussprache formuliert. Kimmel. Will ich die auch nicht sagen. Und außerdem will ich ja auch nicht den anderen so auf die Nase drücken, dass sie es falsch machen. Weil das ist auch wieder arrogant. Das heißt, in dem Moment, in dem Denzel sagt, hey Leute, übrigens, by the way, nach vierzig Jahren, zwei Oscars und drei Emmys, noch mal ganz kurz, ich heiße Denzel und alle so, oh nee, jetzt, was sagt man jetzt, sagt man es richtig, sagt man es falsch, wie soll man jemanden korrigieren, wenn er es falsch sagt, weil ich arbeite ja im Interesse des Schauspielers. Es gibt nur Probleme. Wie der berühmte Regisseur Martin Scorsese. Die wenigsten wissen, dass er Scorsese ausgesprochen wird. Und man muss sich ja hüten, wirklich dann auch den richtigen Namen zu benutzen, weil es wirkt immer so ein bisschen zu, als würde man sich zu viel Mühe geben mit jemandem, mit einem Namen. Ich hatte zum Beispiel eine Ex-Freundin und die hat immer, die hat irgendwann von einem, also als ich noch mit ihr zusammen war, hat sie immer von einem André gesprochen. Ein André und sie hat immer, sobald sie mit mir über diesen Menschen geschrieben hat, hat sie sich sehr viel Mühe beim Namen gegeben. Sie hat nämlich immer diesen Strich über dem E. Noch in der Tastatur, ja und das war der Moment, wo ich Schluss gemacht habe.. Ich wusste, okay, da geht was zwischen den beiden. Sie gibt sich zu viel Mühe, diesen Namen richtig zu schreiben. Bei WhatsApp oder in einer anderen Messenger-App. Keine Ahnung, was da war. Sie hat ihn auch immer mit so einem spanischen Einschlag gesagt. Also da war Jochen da, Monika und André. Und na ja, wir hatten eine schöne Zeit. Und verstehst du dich gut mit André? André, meinst du? Na ja, geh, also er ist natürlich eine feurige Personaligkeit und sowas.
Ja, und ich war immer Steffen, da hätte ich auch schon drauf kommen können, dass wir nicht zusammenpassen. Ja, stimmt schon, ich meine, zum Glück hat Scorsese das dritte See weggenommen nach zwei Jahren, wo er sich dachte, es ist einfach albern, es wird nichts mehr, lassen wir bei Scorsese, CZ, man weiß es nicht. Ganz kurz, bei Samuel L. Jackson, warum lässt er das L nicht einfach weg? Du brauchst das L nicht. Es ist, sagen wir mal, optional, die Initiale in der Mitte zu benutzen. Klassischer Anfängerfehler für Eltern. Der zweite Name darf nicht den ersten Buchstaben haben, genauso wie der letzte des ersten Namen. Du kannst sich Samuel Larry Jackson heißen, weil dann denkst du mal, Moment, du heisst Samuel Larry? Samuel Larry? Was ist das für ein Name? Samuel L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L. L Samuel L. Es ist wirklich doof. Und dann fängt's auch an, keinen Spaß mehr zu machen. Es ist so vermeidbar. Namen sind vermeidbar. Aber es ist lustig, dass wir alle ausgedachte Namen haben. Also, das ist ja ... Wenn man sich darüber Gedanken macht, dass wir wirklich wie so ein Sim sind, wo man sich einen Namen für ausdenken musste, ist schon weird. Wir haben ja alle ... Man muss als es gegeben war, Florian istian, so. Aber dass es sich jemand ausgedacht hat, das ist schon interessant. Und bei dir hat man sich ja auch so ein bisschen mehr Mühe gegeben, weil das ja irgendwie Namen aus der zweiten Reihe eher, muss man sagen, oder dritten. Ja, aber sind wir denn an dem Punkt, weil ich glaube, man ... Also in Deutschland ist es sehr schwer, sich neue Namen offiziell geben zu lassen. Ich glaube, in Amerika ist das sehr leicht, aber in Deutschland, glaube ich, muss zumindest männlich und weiblich
klar unterscheidbar sein. Also wenn du jetzt sagst Milky Way,
sagt man, ja, es könnte,
weiss nicht mehr nicht, es ist weiblich oder männlich.
Also ist man an dem Punkt, wo man sagt,
jetzt bitte keine Kreativität mehr und jetzt lebt bitte
einfach mit den Namen, die ihr habt.
Das war ja bis sonst nicht so.
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Ich glaube, man kann auch in Deutschland
relativ gut noch Namen hinzufügen.
Ich glaube, es wird nur halt schwierig bei sowas wie Nazi. Also du kannst den so nicht Nazi nennen oder Mickey Mouse, weil das geschützt ist zum Beispiel. Oder Volvic. Das stimmt. Also ich glaube, da hört es dann irgendwann auch. Naja, die würden sich natürlich über Werbung freuen. Es gab ja tatsächlich, ich habe ja früher immer die Screen Fun gelesen. Das war der Gaming-Ableger der Bravo, was ich erst viel später entdeckt hatte.
Was? Wirklich?
Ja, das gehört zum selben Verlag.
Warum sagen die nicht einfach Bravo Games? Wie Bild, Bild Sport?
Ist das nicht so wie beim Essen, wo sowieso alles derselben Firma gehört, wo man sagt, Pepsi ist viel besser als Cola und dann sagt der gleiche Arsch, der Denzel sagt, das gehört übrigens beides zur selben Firma.
Und du denkst, ja, so what?
Das ist alles Kraft und das ist alles Nestlé.
Moment mal, geht da was zwischen dir und Nestlé, Stefan?
Dann zieh doch mit Nestlé zusammen. Ich habe immer Nestle gesagt, Nestle.
Und da in der Screenfun stand mal drin so als Funfact, by the way. Da stand drin, ja, obskure Fakten aus aller Welt. Es gab zur Eröffnung des Spiels ... Sorry, das ist der Punkt. Was? Das ist der Punkt, wo die Folge knickt einfach. Der was? Das neue Spiel zum Film oder andersrum, ich weiss
gar nicht mehr, es ging zumindest
das Versprecherschleife
war so lang, dass ich vergessen habe.
Ich habe wortwörtlich vergessen, über was
wir sprechen. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
So Wörter wie Denzel und Screenfun
schwirren in meinem Kopf rum, ich habe das Thema
vergessen. Screenfun ging es
darum, um den
neuen Action geladenen Dinosaurier- Shoototer Turok ging es. Und dann haben die gesagt, so, oh, hier, passt auf, Spiel, könnt ihr spielen, aber wir sind ja Print, wir geben noch mehr Informationen als nur die reinen Fakten. Und zwar gab es als Marketingaktion, glaube ich, zehn Kinder, die Turok genannt werden konnten für 10.000 Dollar oder so. Da konntest du dein Kind Turok nennen. Oh, mega geil. Als Werbung, wo ich mir denke, okay, selbst wenn ihr denkt, dieses Spiel ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich und unglaublich über den Durchschnitt hinaus erfolgreich. Moment, selbst dann hat es eine Dauer von zwei Jahren, also ein Videospiel, ein gutes Videospiel, also sowas wie GTA V, ist ein Superspiel. Aber auch das ist nach zwei Jahren so geil, weil du kannst in die Autos einsteigen und du kannst hinfahren, wohin du willst. Du kannst am Zebrastreifen halten, du kannst an roten Ampeln auch halten. Das ist so geil und die Umwelt reagiert halt auf dich. Du kannst mit dem Hubschrauber fliegen und dann kannst du ganz schnell mit dem Motorrad über die Schanze und dann fliegst du physikalisch weit weg. Und das ist so geil, weil du kannst mit anderen Spielern zusammenspielen, aber selbst dieses Spiel ist in zwei Jahren vergessen. Also diese Marketing-Anteilung denkt sich, gut, unser Spiel ist so krass, dass wir, wenn wir heute jetzt zum Release die Kinder Turok nennen, also die ersten acht Jahre eines, also das ist ja so wie bei Haustieren, den Namen von Haustieren verwendet man ja nur, wenn Fremde im Raum sind. Jeder sagt Katze. Oh, die Katze sitzt vorm Fernseher. Du sagst doch auch nicht. Die Katze liegt ungünstig. Du sagst doch auch nicht, Mirello liegt vorm. Da kommst du ja dumm vor. Du sagst dann einfach ja, der Kater ist verschwunden, niemand sagt Valentin ist weg. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Da steht Katze vermisst, da steht nicht Marelle. Ja, du sagst ja, du sagst nur, wenn Fremde im Haus sind, dann sagt man, genauso wie man zu seinem Partner oder sowas, dann nicht mehr Schatzi Mausi sagt, sondern den öffentlichen Vornamen, dann sagt man Denzelel, Schatz, kannst du bitte mir die Butter nochmal reichen? Auch nur, wenn Fremde im Haus sind. Das ist schon richtig.. Genauso ist es bei kleinen Kindern auch, da sagt man ja auch nie,
Tu-Rock, sondern die ersten fünf Jahre ist es halt so, ja, das Kind schreit.
Kind.
Entschuldigung, wen meinst du genau, das Kind des Nachbarns,
Turnbeutel, Pflaumen, nee, ich mein unser, mein unser Kind, Tu-Rock.
Unser Kind, was wir nach dem Spiel benannt haben.
Tu-Rock-Consentine.
Nach diesem Minigame, was es mal gab.
Minesweeper, Minesweeper, leg das weg! Sonic the Hedgehog 2 The Return of Falco, bitte, komm hier rein! Ohne Scheiss, Robin Williams hat seine Tochter Zelda genannt. Nach dem Spiel Zelda. Und tatsächlich muss man sagen, der hat auch Werbung gemacht. Für glaube ich die Nintendo 3DS und das Zelda-Spiel dafür.
Und das ist natürlich geil, weil dann hat halt Nintendo diese Werbung gedreht
und unten drunter stand dann Zelda Williams,
benannt nach dem Spiel Zelda, die Tochter von Robin Williams.
Mega cool eigentlich.
Wenn man das als Werbegag nutzen kann, ist das schon geil.
Vielleicht war es aber auch nur ein Gag, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Naja, aber ...
Ich check das mal. Aber Zelda war schon vor dem Spiel ein Name. Oder? Also, Shigeru Miyamoto hat sich nicht den Namen einfach so ausgedacht. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, ich wurde nach dem Spiel benannt, wo du sagst, ja, das Spiel wurde auch nach irgendjemandem benannt. Genau, bei mir wird oft gefragt, ob ich nach Stefan Raab benannt wurde, weil das halt ein großer Star war. Dann denke ich mir die ganze Zeit, aber das ist schon klar, Stefan ist ein häufiger Name. Das ist nicht, die Eltern von Stefan Raab haben sich diesen Namen nicht ausgedacht. Das ist auch die dimmste Frage, die man gestellt bekommt, wirklich. Zelda Williams, da. Wer ist denn dein Lieblings Stefan? Nach welchem Stefan wärst du denn gerne benannt geworden? Stefan Raub war ja schon cool da, muss man sagen. Ja. Oder Stefan Imarillo, der berühmte italienische Bildhauer. Stefan Zweig zum Beispiel. Aber auch zum Beispiel in der Götterwelt, bei den Ägyptern, da gab es ja, die hatten ja keinen Bock mehr und die haben gesagt, und das finde ich gut, ich finde es so, ich mag gesellschaftliche Aufräumaktionen. Nicht im Nazi-Sinne, Leute, Leute, senkt den Hashtag bitte. Sondern einfach mal so aufräumen. Wir haben zu viele Namen, wir haben zu viele Strassen, lassen wir was zusammenlegen. Und das haben die Ägypter gemacht, die haben zwei Götter zusammengelegt. Einer hieß Reh und der andere hieß Atum und danach hieß Ein Gott Atum Reh. haben die einfach zusammengelegt und die haben einfach gesagt, so neuer Gott
so und ich glaube, so ist es vielleicht bei Namen
auch gewesen, dass früher gab es Steh
und Fahnen und mal gesagt, das ist so
Bullshit, ihr habt keinen Bock mehr.
Lass uns die zu Stefan zusammenlegen.
Das heißt, du vereinst das alles schon
in dir zusammen, ohne es zu wissen.
Ja, benannt wurde sie
nach der Prinzessin aus dem The Legend of Zelda-Spielen.
Den ersten Stein wiedergelegte sie 2004 mit ihrer Achso so, da war schon die Info vorbei. Aber wir können trotzdem noch kurz erfahren, wo sie den ersten Stein für Karriere gelegt hat, nämlich in der Rolle als Melissa Loggia mit dem grossen Schwarm des Hauptcharakters in House of D. Aha. Ja, spannend. Toll. Das ist interessant, oder? Aber tatsächlich habe ich letzte Woche erzählt, ich schreibe ja mittlerweile mit Japanern, um die zu korrigieren, und das Blöde ist immer, dass immer wenn ich mich vorstelle, es gibt nämlich weder dieselbe für Ste noch die für Fun im japanischen, heisst meinen Namen kann man nicht schreiben, so richtig. Das heißt, es sieht dann immer, ich habe mittlerweile gelernt, mit diesen quasi, ich habe mir eine iPhone-Tastatur auch eingestellt, dass ich jetzt auch die japanische Tastatur benutzen kann.
Und das ist halt echt weird, weil dann kann ich halt diese Schriftzeichen benutzen und in der Mitte steht halt einfach mein ausgeschriebener Name, Stefan, und dann wieder die Schriftzeichen. Es sieht immer aus, wenn man das kennt aus Filmen, wenn jemand in einer anderen Sprache spricht. Marolo, de de de de de de, Stefan, de de Stefan da de de de de de de de de de weisst du das klingt immer falsch wenn der Name darin vorhanden ist.
Aber der Vorteil ist immer, dass du immer weisst, wenn andere im Raum über dich sprechen, über dich lästern, wenn sie können,
,,Chin-Tong-Tao, to, hey, to, mam, to, Stefan, äh, zog, da, ein riesen Arschloch, de no, da, da.
W-w-w-w-w-w, was haben sie da gesagt?
Nee, nee, nee, wir meinten, das ist das Wort für so diese langen Wolken, ganz langen.
Krieg ich denn jetzt die Hühnchen süss-sauer mit dem extra Avocado-Streifen und die Cola-Light, die ich bestellt habe? Ganz kurz, ich muss mir kurz was bestellen. Auch eine gute Idee. Ich habe nämlich auch unglaublich Hunger. Lass uns gleichzeitig was bestellen. Ja, es verschwendet sich. Diese Zeiten, die wir aufnehmen. Ich weiß. Also, Lieferheld oder Foodora? Das ist doch die grosse Frage. Nee, das möchte ich jetzt nicht nicht sagen. Ich möchte keine Werbung dafür machen, aber ihr wisst alle was. Wie Werbung dafür machen? Mein grosses Problem ist, ich bin immer zu hungrig, um erfolgreich zu bestellen. Ich klicke mir irgendwas zusammen und denke mir, oh geil, darauf habe ich Bock. Und ganz am Ende heißt es immer, wir liefern leider nicht an dieser Adresse. Ich weiß, du bist massiv enttäuscht und es ist dann schlecht. Und dann auf allem das Problem ist, ab dann ist alles andere nicht mehr gut genug. Weißt du, bevor du die Bestellung gemacht hast, dachtest du nicht, ah, okay, vielleicht mal Indisch, vielleicht Sushi oder sowas. Aber nachdem du schon die Bestellung, das ist, glaube ich, die Magie des Warenkorbs. Was mal im Warenkorb ist, ist der Standard für alles danach. Wenn du es dann mal im Warenkorb hattest, dann kannst du nicht mehr loslassen danach. Was holst du dir? Das ist auch das Schlimmste, wenn du im Supermarkt bist und dein wortwörtlicher Warenkorb, dein Einkaufswagen,
ist irgendwann weg zum Beispiel.
Ich habe den schon ein paar Mal verloren.
Und dann, was machst du denn dann?
Dann gehst du dann nicht nochmal einkaufen.
Das ist ein Kollege passiert.
Ein Kollege hat die beste Story erlebt.
Er war bei Ikea und hat sich wirklich über, das ist ja auch ein Akt, ne?
Ikea ist ja Sport und es ist vor allem Event, du bist da den Tag über.
Und da hat er sich den ganzen Tag über den Wagen vollgepackt und dann war er an der Kasse und hat gemerkt, dass er ein Portemonnaie geklaut wurde.
Was?
Weil er den Wagen mal irgendwo hat stehen lassen. Heißt, er musste dann den ganzen vollgepackten Wagen.
Oh nein!
Und du hast dich ja schon mit den Möbeln angefreundet, die waren ja schon in deinen Gedanken, standen die ja schon bei dir, ne?
Und du hast den ganzen Tag mit diesen Möbeln verbracht, die du durch diesen riesen Laden, diese Stadt geschoben hast. Das heißt, die waren alle verloren. Und dann war er auch noch genau an der Kasse, weil Ikea hat ein Jubiläum. Und dann war er genau an der Kasse, die ausgelost wurde. Nein. Weil dann kamen dann so Leute von Ikea in diesen tollen gelben Outfits und haben gesagt, so, wir machen jetzt eine Tombola und wer gewinnt, der kriegt seinen Einkauf geschenkt. Und tatsächlich wurde seine Kasse von diesen 20 ausgewählt. Nein, wie gut ist das denn? Aber der vor ihm, der nur die Teelichter gekauft hat, der hat seinen Einkauf geschenkt bekommen. Entschuldigung, kann ich noch kurz vor. Aber er ist tatsächlich ... Er ist an einer Katastrophe, also er ist auf einer Katastrophe voll zu, aber dann an dem möglichen sehr einfachen Ausweg noch vorbeigeschlittert. Also die maximale Doppelkatastrophe, muss man sagen. Ey, vor allem, ich bestelle Sushi und Sushi ... Ich auch, ich auch, ich auch! Aber mein Problem ist, dass ich einfach nicht weiss, was das alles bedeutet. Und da gibt es so manche Seiten, wo du kein Bild hast. Und dann ist es einfach, also klar, ich verstehe fremde Kulturen respektieren und so, man soll sich auch mit dem Essen beschäftigen und mit der Kultur und so weiter. Aber kann man nicht uns dummdeutschen eine kleine Hand reichen? Hier hast du jetzt Futomaki mit Lachs, Sparg, nee, mit Gurke, Rettich und Karnibu. Soll ich jetzt wissen, was Karnibu bedeutet? Ist das eine Sängerin oder ist das ein Vorname? Was genau soll das sein? Und da muss ich immer googeln. Sushi bestellen besteht bei mir zu 80 Prozent aus Googeln, weil man immer nicht genau weiß, was das bedeutet. Oh, das habe ich aber, ich muss echt sagen, dass ich indisches Essen noch nicht ganz verstanden habe. Aha, indisch, aber ist geil. Ja, super, aber ich verstehe das nicht, weil es gibt das normale, das Default-Gericht, Chicken Tikka Masala, das Vanille-Eis-Indiens, Chicken Tikka Masala, das ist Standardgericht. Schnitzel mit Pommes, das Indische. Aber jetzt gibt es, muss man sagen, dann haben die noch acht andere Gerichte, die ähnlich heißen, die ich alle bei Google eingebe und die exakt genauso aussehen, mit kleinen Farbnuancen. Es ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr ins Rötliche gehend. Keine Kritik direkt aus Indien, aber ich glaube, die haben es ein bisschen mit der Soße übertrieben. Jedes Gericht sieht gleich aus, weil du hast alles unter dem Soßenspiegel. Und Sushi ist das genau Gegenteil, da gibt es keine Soße. Aber zum Beispiel, es gibt hier verschiedene, wir wollen einfach nur Hunger machen, allen Leuten, die gerade zuhören. Gekochte Nigiri, mit Oktopus, verstehe ich, mit mariniertem Aal, verstehe ich, mit Garnelen, verstehe ich, mit Surimi. Ja, Leute, was soll denn Surimi? Mit Horenzo Gomai, ah, okay. Da gibt es doch bestimmt auch ein deutsches Wort dafür, oder ist es jetzt, ah, hier schön, Avocado-Maki. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Teigtasche versus Giozza. Ja. Giozzam. Oh, Spargel-Maki. Spargel-Maki? Spargel-Maki! Nee, Spargel-Maki ist super. Und natürlich muss immer mit dabei Edamame. Oh, hier gibt es kein Edamame. Si, Edamame. Ich glaube, ich mag Edamame nur, weil so viel Salz drauf ist. Edamame ist für mich einfach ein Vorwand, einfach nur Salz zu essen. Ich glaube, am liebsten würde ich einfach nur so einen schönen Esslöffel Salz. Ja, das habe ich ja, als ich bei der Saftkur war, da habe ich abends echt Salz gegessen. Also vielleicht habe ich doch gecheatet. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob da die Definition anfängt, also mit nichts essen. Aber ich hatte einfach das Gefühl, ich brauche einfach, mein Körper braucht Salz. Dann habe ich abends mir auf meinen Handrücken Salz geträufelt und dann meine Handrücken abgelegt. Und dann ging mein Blick so zum Fenster und es war schon dunkel, meine Wohnzimmer war beleuchtet und ich wohne wie gesagt im Erdgeschoss. Wenn mich da jemand gesehen hat, wenn ich mit dem Salzstreuer in meinem Wohnzimmer sitze, es läuft nichts im Fernsehen und so, aber ich sitze einfach auf der Couch und das ist meine Beschäftigung gerade. Aber vor allem alle dachten, du trinkst alleine Tequila, weil da gibt es ja dieses mit Zitrone, Salz und einfach denkt, du hättest einfach so eine Pappflasche Tequila vor dich setzen und alle so, na, du hast einen schönen Abend, gut alleine, ich weiß nicht, ob man das auch alleine macht, ob man sich vor den Fernseher setzt und dann nochmal Schönes mit der Zitrone macht. Das ist dann wieder erbärmlich. Ich bin ja schon bei PayPal. Ich mache schon die PayPal-Kaufobwicklung. Ja, ich bin in einem kritischen Mindestbestellwert 15 Euro, ich habe gerade 14 im Warenkorb. Was macht man jetzt? Oh, ich bin schon bei 19, ich bin bei 19,30. Das ist ein teures Essen für mich, muss ich sagen. Die Sache ist die, also ich bin hier in Sushi-Bestell-Restaurant und es gibt ja, Edamame ist ja wahnsinnig beliebt. Das sind ja diese grünen Bohnen, die man dann so weg snacken kann, wo Salz drauf ist. Und ich denke mal so, warum gibt es immer noch manche Sushi-Bestell-Orte, die das nicht haben? Und dann denke ich mir, die machen das wahrscheinlich aus Prinzip nicht. Die werden ja hundertmal am Tag gefragt werden, oh, haben sie Edamame? Nein.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es so eine Art Beleidigung für die japanische Kultur, dass man ständig Edamame ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es überhaupt nicht japanisch oder passt da gar nicht rein.
Reduzieren wir es darauf nicht. Wie ein Spanier, der nicht Tequila serviert.
Wie die Ärzte, die eben nicht Westerland und Männer sind Schweine spielen auf dem Konzert, weißt du?
Weil es immer kommt und jemand will es nicht mehr spielen. Also die billigsten Gerichte sind einmal Kokossuppe mit Gemüse für zwei Euro. Aber zwei Euro, Kokos ist eigentlich recht selten, ne? Also das ist recht teuer. Ich habe mal Kokosmilch gekauft, das war so teuer. Manchmal hat man ja so einen Einkauf, man kauft so drei Items, also so drei Gegenstände, und dann so 24,60 Euro bitte. Und du denkst dir so, einer von euch drei lausern, wer ist es denn? Ist es die Gurke, ist es die Mysteriösendose aus dem Asia-exotisch-Bereich? Und dann kostet so eine fucking Kokosmilch halt mal 21 Euro. Und du so, okay, anscheinend habe ich mir irgendwann in meinem Leben abgewöhnt, auf Preisschilder zu schauen. Das ist eigentlich ein riesen Luxus. Also das ist man wirklich nicht gewohnt. Nee, das musst du schon auch wertschätzen. Ich habe am Wochenende, da dachte ich mir, komm, jetzt kochst du mal. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Kochen ist, streng genommen. Eigentlich war es mehr Zutaten zusammengewirfen, aber ich habe eine Poké Bowl gemacht. Wow, ich habe auch am Wochenende eine Poké Bowl. Ist es Kochen? Weil streng genommen kochst du nie was. Naja, aber... Es wird nie was gebraten. Alles, was ich unter Kochen sehe, also die ersten Wortassoziationen zu kochen, kommen nicht drin vor. Du schneidest halt Dinge und schmeißt sie zusammen. These? Das war total lecker und ich habe mir... Ja, These? These, Kochen beinhaltet eine Aggregatzustandsveränderung. Oh, dann ist es nichts. Dann habe ich nicht... Genau. Also ich habe Lachs kleiner geschnitten. Was du gemacht hast, ist Mischen. Du bist ein DJ, aber kein Koch. These, alles, was auf chefkoch.de steht, mit Rezepten, die du dann umsetzen kannst, ist gleich kochen oder backen. Jedenfalls habe ich das gemacht und ich bin extra in einen guten Feinschweckerladen gegangen, um mir den Fisch zu holen, weil den isst du ja roher Lachs. Und da dachte ich mir, den kannst du jetzt nicht einfach, du kannst nicht irgendwo Lachs auftauen oder sowas, vielleicht geht das auch, aber ich dachte mir, ich hol mal guten Lachs. Und das war auch echt teuer dann und ich habe die meiste Zeit aber damit verbracht, die Zutaten zu finden, weil das war so ein Zitronen, Gras, Lauchzwiebel, Poke Bowl-Ding mit Sesam, Öl und Kram. Und ich habe wirklich einfach drei Stunden lang durch einen Rewe, der war noch nicht gross, der Rewe. Ich bin einfach nur, ich habe das nicht gefunden, die meisten Zutaten. Und die Verkäufer dachten auch schon, ich glaube, die meisten Leute in dem Laden haben mich für ein Ladendetektiv gehalten. Weil es nicht aussah, als ob ich wirklich aktiv einkaufe, sondern einfach nur nervös mich umschaue die ganze Zeit. Aber das macht dich natürlich verdächtig für den Kaufhausdetektiv. Ja, ich weiß, wir waren dann auch irgendwann per Du, weil er mir gefolgt ist, offensichtlich, weil er dachte, das kann nicht sein. Finde ich auch einen noch der lustigsten Strassencomedy, glaube ich, kann man das Genre im Allgemeinen nennen, es gibt es überhaupt Christian Ulmen in seiner Unter-Ulmen-Sendung, damals auf MTV, ganz, ganz früh. Da gibt's auf iTunes so eine Komplettbox, wo man sich noch die Sachen angucken kann. Und da gibt's einen Skit, wo sie Kaufhausdetektiv spielen. Ja, also die, ich glaub, er, und dann hat das mit so einem Mann gemacht. Und dann nehmen die halt so Leute fest und dann so ulkige, ulkige Sachen. Und dann läuft dieses Skit so vor, und dann denkst du dir, ah, okay, lustig, unterhaltsam. Und dann irgendwann wollen die so jemanden verhaften, und dann sagen die, der, den sie verhaften wollte, nee, wir sind der Kaufhausdetektiv und verhaften ihn. Und ich mir, what? Das ist mal eine Wendung, wo ich dachte, Alter, scheiß auf Story for Sam, scheiß auf Sixth Sense, das ist mal ein Twist, ja, die so ... Das ist ein Plottwist. Wir tun jetzt, als wären wir der Kaufhausfer, der die tief zack verhaftet Gefängnis. Aber ich finde auch lustig, dass du sagst, Ulmen und dieser andere Mann, und nichts beschreibt besser, dass seine Karriere nicht gelaufen ist wie geplant. Wie wenn man beschreibt, ja gut, Ulmen und dieser andere Mann, er hat das mit so einem anderen Mann gemacht, man wird von uns auch mal irgendwann sprechen mit, ja, Florentin und dieser andere Typ haben mal diesen diesen Podcast gemacht. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es ist das Problem, man kann auch also das ist halt so dieser kleiner Fisch im grossen Teich oder grosser Teich im kleinen Fisch Paradox, dass man so denkt, okay, ich habe jetzt die Möglichkeit nach Paris zu ziehen, zu den coolen Künstlern, bin dann aber einer von vielen. Und so hat der Mann sich das auch überlegt. W der irgendwie in Radio Bremsburg geblieben, wäre der der Krasse gewesen. Radio Bremsburg, ganz kurz, wo ist der Gedanke abgerutscht, einfach, fuck jetzt einfach Radio Bremen zu sagen. Ich wollte nicht Bremen sagen, weil dann beleidige ich alle bei Radio Bremen und ich liebe Radio Bremen. Radio Breemsburg.
Warte.
Also, ganz kurz, Stichwort Anmerkung für das Restaurant.
Hast du da was eingegeben?
Was? Um Gottes Willen nein.
Weil ich denke, dann rotzen die doch sofort da rein.
Du kannst so viel auswählen, wähl dir einfach das aus, wo du nichts anmerken musst.
Als Notiz.
Naja, aber bei mir ist es gar nicht so leicht, zur richtigen Tür zu kommen. Ah, okay, ich verstehe. Ich weiß auch immer nicht, Etage. Das haben die besonders gern, das haben die besonders gern. Vor allem bei... Meine Wohnung hat, meine Tür steht offen, ich habe keine Klingel, ich wohne da eigentlich gar nicht, ich komme ihnen einfach entgegen, rufen sie mich einfach an. Und bitte an die Fensterscheibe, ram-pa-pam-pam, dann geht automatisch die Tür auf. Trinkgeld liegt im Müll. Au, ich habe aber verpasste Lieferzeit. Naja, das passt schon, wenn ich jetzt abschicke. Meiner ist gegen 22.43 Uhr. Und das ist, wir haben jetzt 21.18 Uhr. Das ist eine Frechheit, das sind anderthalb Stunden um 23 Uhr dadurch vorher ins Bett zu gehen. Naja, aber heute ist ja Donnerstag. Heute ist ja richtig viel los. Warum ist das jetzt zu spät geworden? Das ist auch gemein. Nein! Jetzt ist genau das passiert! Was ist passiert? Fick dich einfach, liefert nicht an die von Ihnen eingegebene Lieferadresse. Das ist doch nicht dein fucking Ernst, hier steht die... Oh, jetzt habe ich... Oh Mann! Du schmeckst schon das Salz. Du schmeckst schon das Salz auf deiner Zunge. Jetzt ist genau das, das kann doch nicht dein Ernst sein. Ich hab meine Adresse ganz am Anfang eingegeben. Oh nein. Ach Mann, ich hatte genau die 15 Euro vollgemacht. Ich hab noch eins gefunden, das ein Euro kostet. So eine einzelne Sushi-Rolle. So diese Trauerrolle einfach so. ihr nehmt mich doch nur mit, weil ihr den Mindestbestellwert voll machen wollt. Was dann auch meistens, weil es ja dann auch irgendwie immerhin einen Euro kostet, meistens diese Garnele ist, die so traurig sich draufgelegt hat. Wie so eine Garnele, die sich traurig zum Sterben auf Reis gelegt hat. Wirklich? In der Hoffnung, dass ... Jemand will mich essen? Ja, sieht aus. Ja. Das ist doch der Film von Seth Rogen, ist doch mit in Essen, ne? Die haben doch auch so, die freuen sich, wenn sie gegessen werden. Sausage Party. Nee, ich bin ein bisschen traurig, wenn sie gegessen werden. Nee, ich glaube, am Anfang freuen sie sich, dass sie eingekauft werden, aber dann erfahren sie, was das bedeutet, was Einkaufen eigentlich bedeutet. Es ist ähnlich wie wir. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir Karriere machen, aber dann, wenn wir merken, was Karriere eigentlich bedeutet, dann wollen wir es nicht mehr. Also hier ist nämlich wie gefressen werden. Hier gibt es einen Laden, der heißt Sushi für Hamburg. Und wenn die jetzt hier nicht herliefern, dann bin ich wirklich enttäuscht. Aber die haben vor allem... Sushi für was, wenn nicht für Hamburg? Die haben vor allem Mindestbestellwert 14,90 Euro. Da denke ich mir, clever, clever, weil die wahrscheinlich irgendjemanden unterbieten wollen. Ich höre dich nicht mehr, ich rufe dich nochmal an. Ah nee, sorry. Das muss man einfach sagen, wenn er in Hamburg ist und nicht in Köln, wir haben noch keine richtige Lösung dafür gefunden für dieses Problem. Ich rufe ihn nochmal an. Ich rufe ihn nochmal an. Hallo. Ja, jetzt geht er nicht dran. Hallo. Hallo. Sorry, ich bin aus Versehen auf mein Handy gekommen und habe stumm gedotzt. Ja, aus Versehen. Ich habe dich aus Versehen stumm gedotzt. Hast du die, ich verstehe, dass du sauer bist wegen dieser ganzen Sushi-Sache. Ich war ein bisschen aus Versehen. Es ist kein Grund, jetzt hier diesen Unterhaltungspodcast auf die Probe zu kommen. Aber vor allem, vielleicht habe ich jetzt noch die Chance, heute schön meinen Edamame zu bekommen. Nein, die haben auch keinen Edamame, das ist doch verrückt. Die haben keinen Bock mehr auf dieses Image, dass aus Japan nur Kinderpornos und grünen Bohnen kommen. Die wollen die Image aufpolieren, glaube ich. Hey, hey, Japan ist mehr als Plus. Du bist jetzt der Verteidiger von ganz Japan. Hi, hi. Mit Surimi und Avocado. Was ist denn Surimi, niemand weiss es!
Der bessere Reakt wäre gewesen, was ist denn Avocado, niemand weiss es. Florentin, den hast du liegen lassen. Ja, wir werden so viele Kommentare bekommen, sie, oh, jetzt habe ich Hunger, jetzt will ich mir auch was bestellen, ist das die cleverste Brugplace mit aller Zeiten? Diese eingelegte Fisch.
Ja.
Ey, ganz im Ernst, ich habe jetzt
eine Switch
und ich habe, wo wir gerade auch bei Zelda waren,
ich habe die letzten Monate auch
Zelda gespielt. Ja, Breath of the Wild.
Breath of the Wild und es ist
wirklich ein ganz tolles Spiel und ich
bin bei dem ersten Endgegner jetzt.
Ich bin in so einem Elefanten, laufe die ganze Zeit
auf dem Elefanten rum und
muss diesen Endgegner besiegen und mir gelingt es nicht. Und das ist der Grund, warum ich das Spiel jetzt aufgehört habe. Es ist furchtbar, es ist einfach ätzend. Ich will ja auch nicht gut sein in dem Spiel, also ich schaffe es nicht, diesen zu besiegen, ich schaffe es nicht, ich habe mir diverse Internet-Tutorials angeguckt und so einen Scheiss, ich kriege das einfach nicht hin, diesen Typen zu besiegen mit seinem langen Scheissschwert, der mich überall hinerreicht und mich sofort tötet, wenn er mich einmal trifft. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich Spiele nicht mag, ist mir aufgefallen. Ich mag Spiele einfach nicht, weil ich will ja nicht gut sein in dem Spiel. Ich will einfach die Geschichte miterleben und so ein bisschen da rumlaufen und die Landschaften genießen und überrascht werden von den tollen Ungeheuern, die da rumlaufen und neue Schwerter sammeln.
Aber ich will auch nicht andauernd gegen so ein Minigame spielen.
Ich glaube, ich habe einen Tipp für dich.
Filme.
Weil da musst du nichts machen, sondern kriegst nur die Story.
Da muss ich nicht auf A und B drücken.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist eine lange Cutscene.
Hä?
Ich dachte, ich wäre sehr gut einfach in Game of Thrones. Nee, nee, nee, du musst da gar nichts machen. Aber ich hab meinen Controller die ganze Zeit immer noch in der Hand und sprückel die ganze Zeit auf A und weiche aus. Wie gesagt, lass es einfach mal weg, du steuerst da nicht. Was? Das sind echte Menschen, die haben das schon gemacht. Das ist schon vorbei. Du gehst eigentlich in die Vergangenheit. Aber Breaking Bad war echt das beste Third-Person-Game, muss ich sagen. Ja, das war echt geil. Das hat mir richtig viel Spaß gemacht. Sorry, ich hänge jetzt gerade bei 14,50 Euro. Und jetzt was zu finden, was 50 Cent kostet. Vor allem, ich habe mal... Ach, nimm doch, das ist für Euro. Es gibt ja ein, glaube ich, in der Leihendecker gibt es ja die bunten Burger, dieses vegane Burger-Restaurant. Und die haben auf der Karte, verrückt, die haben auf der Karte einen Baum. Und du kannst einen Baum mitzahlen und dann wird ein Baum gepflanzt. Ah, supergut Idee! Das kannst du dann nicht essen, sondern du bestellst es halt einfach, weil es auf der Karte steht. Und denkst du, okay, noch einen Baum. Hey, Foodora, mach einfach den Rest Spenden. Genau, das ist supergut, das erinnere ich mir auch, dass ich jetzt hier für 40 Cent, wie viel Baum wollen Sie, 40 Cent, so zwei kleinere Äste und das ich dann einfach dazu bestelle. Das ist, glaube ich, eine geniale Idee. Gibt es ja auch im Supermarkt, Aufrunden bitte, was, was ich, na, Moment, stopp, Einhaken, Einhaken. Ein tolles System, ich finde das gut. Ja, aber hast du es schon niemals gemacht? Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber nicht, weil du geizig bist, sondern weil dieses Aufrunden bitte. Und die Kassiererin, wie bitte? Ja, ich möchte diese Aufrundenaktion. Ach so, und dann musst du dir was eintippen und alle in der Rolle rollen die Augen und denkst, es ist einfach zu. Es ist mir unangenehm. Ja, vor allem ich bin auch immer jemand, der die Texte, die er sagt, auch vom Bäcker, durchgeht in seinem Kopf. Und du willst keine Fehler, du willst dir nicht mehr Raum geben, selbst Fehler machen zu können. Die Chance zu versagen ist zu groß, das stimmt schon. Vor allem, du hast diesen Deliver-Druck vor der ganzen Kasse, hinter dir stehen halt immer fünf Leute. Ja, das stimmt schon. Es wäre gut, wenn es da so ein diskretes Zeichen für gibt, oder so einen geflügelten Ausdruck, wieimmtso. Ja, ich glaube, das gibt es auch schon.
Ich glaube, da gab es sogar einen Gerichtsprozess,
weil so etwas wie Stimmtso zu sehr Alltagssprache ist
und man dann das verwechseln kann
und die Leute das vielleicht gar nicht spenden wollten.
Und dann musste Kinder gegen Afrika
Millionen an Spenden wieder zurückgeben.
Afrika gegen Kinder.
Nein, du meinst Afrika gegen Kinder.
Ja, genau, weil die gesagt haben, das sind unrechtmäßige Spenden.
Und dann musste Millionen an Spenden wieder zurückgeben, weil die gesagt haben, das sind unrechtmäßige Spenden und da sind Millionen Menschen gestorben, einfach nur wegen so einem dummen Fehler. Also letzten Endes ist es schwierig. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich vorhin falsch gemacht habe. Ich habe nicht die falsche... Also die ganzen Stimmzobrunnen mussten wieder abgerissen werden. Jetzt müssen sie wieder zukippen den Brunnen. Warum? Das kostet doch auch Geld, das macht keinen Sinn. Gib mir die Breize! Gib mir die Breize! Nein! Er hat doch gesagt, es stimmt so. Also, du hast aufgerundet mit was? Wie mit so einem traurigen Garnelchen auf Reis? Ja, ich hab jetzt wieder so ein Avocado-Nigiri. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Am Ende ist es einfach eine Avocado. Ist Nigiri nicht die Schlange von Harry Potter? Oh, gut, hab ich mir letztens angeschaut. Oh, ich bin endlich durch, ich bin endlich durch durch Harry Potter. Boah, das war eine Reise, wirklich. Es war wirklich am Ende ... Es ist eine Reise, es ist ein Ritt. Vor allem, ich hab das immer beim Essen angeschaut, weil ich mir dachte, gut, dann hab ich halt was Leckeres auf der Zunge, dafür was Schweres auf den Augen. Da komm ich durch. Aber ich hab's dadurch immer so assoziiert mit Essen und ich denke, oh geil, Essen und da so, oh nee, muss ich, ich bin jetzt durch, ich bin jetzt endlich durch. Ah, das ist der indische Film, weil du indisch gegessen hast während des Films. Nee, tatsächlich, immer wenn ich indisch bestelle, schaue ich mir The Joel McHale Show auf Netflix an. Das habe ich wirklich so, da freue ich mich, weil das zusammenpasst. Das ist sehr lustig, aber es ist, das geht es mir auch. Also man muss beim Essen was machen, weil man das Gefühl hat, das reicht gerade nicht als Aktion. Man muss sich immer, ich glaube dieses Second Screen Ding ist mittlerweile auch in allen Lebensbereichen angekommen. Second Thing, du musst immer was parallel machen, weil eine Aktion reicht fast alleine gar nicht mehr, weil du akzeptierst das nicht, weil du so viele Möglichkeiten hast und die Opportunitätskosten so groß sind. Es gibt ja bei der WM, fand ich ganz toll, da gab es ein Angebot, wo du selber Regisseur spielen konntest im Internet, weil du bei den ganzen Spielen quasi auf 14 Kameras zugreifen konntest und dir quasi dein eigenes Spiel selber zusammenschneiden konntest. und du die ganze Zeit, was irgendwann wird es doch dann, finde ich, geht es auch in Richtung Menschenwürde,
weil die ganze Zeit zwei Kameras auf den Trainern waren, die die ganze Zeit nur die Trainer gezeigt haben. Und ich verstehe, dass man das als Live-Regie machen muss, um da einfach hinschneiden zu können, wenn da was passiert oder wenn die Emotionen da sind. Aber dass man das auch ins Internet strepen muss, weiß ich nicht. Nee, das finde ich nicht gut. Weil es ist halt ein langes Spiel, es ist schlimmes Big-Brother-Art. Vor allem die Trainer wollen nicht vor die Kamera. So, ich sag mal so bei ... Es sind Fussballtrainer. Naja, aber ich sag mal so bei Schauspielern oder so, keine Ahnung, wenn du zu einer Preisverleihung gehst, dann gibst du jedes Recht ab, weil dann weisst du, ich hab mich jetzt ein schönes Kleid angezogen, ich bin perfekt geschminkt und so, und dann kannst du nicht sagen, ich wollte nicht gefilmt werden. Aber in einem Fussballspiel, da machst du es für die Leidenschaft das Spiel. Gibt es bei einer Preisverleihung irgendwann mal gefilmt den Moment, wo drei Leute eingeländet wurden, einer gewinnt und einer von denen, der verliert, ist sauer? Das fände ich mal geil. Gibt es das irgendwo im Internet? Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon gedacht. Es ist immer dieses gespielte, natürlich hat der es mehr verdient als ich. Und ich klatsche noch mal. Und ich umarme auch meine Frau. Und trotzdem, und wow, und ich gönne es dem auch viel mehr, er ist ja mehr verdient. Es ist immer dieses gekünstelt. Ja, oder jemand, der sich schlafen stellt. Fuck you, fickt euch, ich wollte gewinnen. Ich will ernste Wut darüber. Oder Überraschung, dass man nicht gewonnen hat. Ich überlege, ob die da schon rauskriegen können, wer gewonnen hat, weil bestimmt dann, also ich meine, die Kamera von dem Gewinner, die verfolgt ihn ja mit auf die Bühne. Das heißt, wenn dein Kameramann Rollstuhlfahrer ist, weißt du genau, oh, wenn da keine Rampe ist, dann habe ich nicht gewonnen oder irgendwie sowas. Die haben doch bestimmt, die sind doch clever. Treferenziell jetzt und aber beim studio hamburg nachwuchspreis er hat erfolgt seit 20 folgen drauf das mal zu erwähnen ja sprich es endlich an wie war das als du bestes nachwuchstalent aller zeiten ever supergeil gut gemacht stefan gewonnen hast erzähl mal und zwar ich saß genau in der mitte ich sa. Es war ein Theater und es gab keine Gänge. Und ich saß exakt in der Mitte. Und wenn ich gewinne, muss die ganze Reihe aufstehen. Es war so ein altes Theater, das Thalier-Theater in Hamburg. Ich weiß nicht, ob du schon mal da warst. Aber es ist sehr alt und dadurch sehr eng. Und ich wusste, dass ich nicht gewinne. Ich war mir mir sicher, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und dann habe ich gewonnen und die ganze Reihe war genervt. Dann kam diese Musik und dann kamen auch so Verfolgungsscheinwerfer und sowas. Und die Verfolgungsscheinwerfer dachten halt, ich wäre wesentlich schneller. Die Verfolgungsscheinwerfer waren mir voraus. Ich habe irgendwann die Verfolgungsscheinwerfer verfolgt, weil die so schnell waren. Und dann musste meine Reihe erst aufstehen, und ich bin da wirklich, wirklich zwei Minuten lang durch die Reihe,
Entschuldigung, sorry, sorry, ich muss ganz kurz nach vorne.
Die Musik hört schon auf, der Loop ist zu Ende.
Und ich dachte, jetzt ist einer von denen gleich,
oh, das ist grad sehr ungünstig, müssen sie jetzt wirklich raus?
Und ich so, ja, ja, das ist ganz kurz, ich muss ganz kurz auf die Bühne.
Das war wirklich sehr unangenehm.
Aber da dachte ich mir, die werden ja wohl keinen Gewinner genau in die Mitte setzen. Aber genau das haben sie getan. Fuck it. Clever, die wollten nicht überraschen. Die wollten echte Emotionen. Es war eine kleine Anspielung tatsächlich auf den ersten Buff da, glaube ich, von The Office, weil der Produzent von The Office sitzt im Rollstuhl. Und als sie dann irgendwann gemerkt haben, oh, auf die Bühne führt eine Rollstuhlrampe, wussten sie schon, dass sie gewonnen hatten, noch bevor sie angesagt wurden. 2002 Referenzen sind immer noch im Spiel. Aber noch besser wäre es tatsächlich, wenn er nicht gewonnen hätte und die nur einfach die echte Emotion, nämlich des Verlierens haben. Ja, das finde ich auch gut. Und der Gewinner ist Forty Towers und der fährt mit dem Skateboard so auf die Bühne. Nimm das, Rollstuhlfahrer, das kannst du nicht. Ja, also ich habe jetzt 30, 40 Minuten Bestellzeit, es wird immer mehr.
40 Minuten? Ich glaube, ich bin eineinhalb Stunden. Das ist schon krass.
Aber ich wohne auch in Deutz und die ganzen Restaurants sind in Köln Mitte.
Heißt, die müssen alle den Rhein überqueren.
Und ich glaube, da kommt immer so eine Additional Time.
Nicht, weil der, weil das ist auch so ein Ding bei Köln, alle glauben, der Rhein wäre unglaublich.
Kölner sind sehr stolz auf ihre Stadt, auf den Rhein
und die beschreiben das ja immer als
einen tollen, grossen, mächtigen Fluss.
Der ist nicht so breit.
Man kommt ja da nicht schnell drüber. Zwei Minuten
und man ist drüber. Aber
Deutz ist wie abgeschieden.
Ach, da wohnst du? Oh,
musst du nicht jetzt langsam los, um noch bis Sonnenuntergang
zu Hause zu sein? Und man sagt so, nee, ich fahre
fünf Minuten nach Hause.
Es ist irgendwie immer interessant. Kölner, die mogeln sich ihre Welt so ein bisschen immer zurecht. Aber auch empathisch. Ja, die Kölner, das ist ein ganz eigenes Völkchen. Ich habe jetzt sehr Hunger eigentlich. Ja, ich habe auch Hunger. Wahrscheinlich alle Hörer auch, wir müssten so Gutscheine rausgeben, dass sich alle jetzt was zu essen kaufen. dass mein Gott, wir sind so doof, wir sind so schlecht im Vermarkten, Wir könnten jetzt so gut irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendeinen Lieferdienstgutschein raushauen oder so was. Gutscheincode PUFO und ihr kriegt 10% Rabatt. Erst mal Hunger machen. Das ist das Problem. Die Podcastwerbung kommt immer am Anfang. Dumm. Die muss immer dann kommen, wenn es genau reinpasst. Ich glaube, das gibt es aber auch. Wir haben noch nie Werbung gemacht, aber das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass wir da unserer Linie treu bleiben. Es gibt ein Produkt, wo ich wirklich sage, da würde ich echt Werbung dafür machen. Das ist wirklich das beste Produkt der Welt. Es gibt ja oft diese Nasendinger, die man in die Nase steckt, damit man nicht mehr schnarchen muss. Dieser Kühlschrank mit dem Taschenkuchen. Ich glaube, bei der Menge von Produkten, die es gibt, wird es lange dauern, bis du drauf kommst.
Und zwar, ich habe in der WG gewohnt in Köln, wohne ich mittlerweile nicht mehr, und zwar meine Mitbewohnerin hatte eine Katze.
Und diese Katze war, glaube ich, nicht dafür gedacht, in der Wohnung gehalten zu werden.
Auf jeden Fall war die ständig hyperaktiv, ist durch die Gegend gerannt. Ach, grausam.
Und die hat auch irgendwann angefangen, in mein Zimmer zu pinkeln, weil ich der Einzige war, der sie ins Zimmer gelassen hat, damit sie ein bisschen Platz hat in der Wohnung, sonst hätte die nur auf dem Flur rumhängen müssen. Und die hat dann angefangen, irgendwann in mein Zimmer zu pinkeln. Und das ist ja wirklich unerträglich. Man kann sich das ja nicht vorstellen, wie das riecht. Das ist wirklich, selbst wenn du das versuchst auszuwaschen, forget it, es funktioniert nicht. Und du denkst dir vor allem, naja gut, in der Priorität der Sinneseindrücke, es gibt ja immer dieses, wärst du lieber blind oder taub oder sowas, du denkst dir, naja, riechen, ist das so wichtig, ist das so wichtig, und du denkst dir, mein Gott, also zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, dein Haus steht in Flammen, kann ich da noch schlafen, wahrscheinlich nicht, mein Haus steht unter Wasser, kann ich da noch schlafen, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber du denkst dir, wenn mein Haus stinkt, kann ich doch noch schlafen?
Man denkt wahrscheinlich schon, aber es ist nicht möglich. Wirklich, es gibt Gerüche, die sind so intensiv, dein Körper sagt einfach, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, du machst gerade nicht schlafen jetzt, du machst gerade alles falsch. und du sagst, nein, nein, nein, pass auf, das ist ungefährlich. Dein Körper sagt wirklich, du bist in der Höhle eines Löwen, so wie es gerade geriecht hier, hau ab! Und dann denkst du einfach, chill, es ist nur Geruch, es ist ja wirklich nur, es ist ja nichts. Es ist ja nicht gefährlich, also das sind ja irgendwie so Moleküle in der Luft oder so, die tun dir ja nichts. Das ist ja nur der Vorbote einer Gefahr. Also wenn jetzt wirklich dein Haus in Flammen steht und alles ist voller Rauch, dann denkt man sich, das riecht nicht gut, aber es ist auch wirklich gefährlich für dich. Aber Geruch, also wenn irgendwas, es riecht sehr intensiv nach, schön nach Plätzchenteig. Und du denkst dir, das ist ja nichts Schlimmes, das ist ja nur, ne? Wobei man muss auch sagen, dass Hunde auch aufwachen, sobald man den Keks vor die Nase hält. Da gibt es ja auch diese lustigen Viral Hits. Ich glaube, man wacht auch auf, wenn es gut riecht. Einfach weil man denkt, Nahrung zu nehmen, jetzt Nahrung zu nehmen, weil es ist da vor deiner Nase. Ja, es ist merkwürdig, aber keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall habe ich dann lange gesucht und dann ist halt immer so das Ding, so was mache ich jetzt, wasche ich jetzt meine Bettwäsche in der Waschmaschine, dann ist sie völlig nass. Kann ich dann schlafen? Kann ich schlafen, wenn mein Bett komplett durchnässt ist? Antwort Nein, auch das geht nicht. Also auf die Heizung hängen, wie lange dauert das? Wie lange braucht das? Also das sind so Fragen, die man sich nie stellt und dann plötzlich einfach die gesamte Nacht nicht schläft. Und das ist ja unangenehm. Und das passiert häufiger. Und irgendwann dachte ich mir, irgendwas muss jetzt passieren gegen dieses verdammte Katzenurin. Und dann habe ich gegoogelt und gefunden, es gibt ein Material, und das findet man noch auf einmal zu leicht, und das arbeitet mit Bakterien. Und dann denkt man sich, ah gut, das ist gut als Verkauf. Weil man denkt sich, ich habe da mit Seife eingerieben und Deo draufgesprüht und so, aber das bringt gar nichts. Die denken weiter. Die denken weiter. Man will direkt das neue Level haben. Genau, das ist so wie bei ... Man will die Chemotherapie haben. Richtig. Das Saubermachnis. Das ist so wie in so einem Videospiel, wo man denkt, so, ah, gegen die Feuerelementare brauche ich Wasserzauber. Und so ist es auch, ah, das ist ja ein Naturangriff, Katze, Katzenurin ist ja ein Naturangriff, also brauche ich auch Natur dagegen, so mit den Bakterien, das ist ja auch natürlich so. Und dann denke ich mir, das hat mich verkauft. Gekauft, brillant, das Zeug ist super, stinkt auch, aber es holt zumindest dann das andere raus. Es stinkt auch? Es stinkt anders, es stinkt so, dass es nicht so schlimm ist. Aber es ist schwierig, aber dieses Bakterien-Anti-Tier-Urin-Spray ist genial. Aber geil, was für ein konkretes Produkt das ist. Ja. Was für ein spezifisches Produkt. Genau das willst du. Aber ist es die Firma, die das herstellt? Weil das kann ich mir vorstellen. Oder ist es ein Produkt einer Geruchsmittelentfernungsfirma? Oder ist es einfach deren Firma? Ich glaube, die machen das. Heissen die Katzahn oder so so und machen halt dieses Katzengeruchsentfernungsmittel? Es ist einerseits sehr speziell, aber auf der anderen Seite kannst du damit, glaube ich, jedes Tier Urin rausmachen, nicht nur Katze. Also Katze ist natürlich das häufigste, aber wenn ich jetzt hier so ein Pfau in mein Wohnzimmer stolzieren würde und sage, jetzt pass mal auf was, jetzt passiert, Kollege, ich bin bereit. Und wenn ihr jetzt anruft, kriegt ihr obendrauf noch die Hundehaarbürste. Vor allem. Wichtig ist ja, also mein Onkel hat mal gesagt, ich kaufe immer in den Baumarkt ein, weil der Berater hat gesagt, passen Sie auf, Sie können hier diese Fliesen kaufen, da gibt es zu Sie die Eckenfliesen, aber ich rate Ihnen, kaufen Sie die normalen Fliesen und sägen Sie die einfach zu, sparen Sie Geld. Und dann hat mein Onkel gesagt, da würde ich immer wieder einen kaufen, weil der Verkäufer hat mein Interesse im Blick, nicht das Interesse des Baumarkts, möglichst viel Umsatz zu machen. So, gut, jetzt dieses Bakterienzeug wird konzentriert geliefert. Man muss es nämlich noch eins zu eins verdünnen mit Wasser, wo man sich denkt, die hätten ja auch einfach das eins zu eins verkaufen können, würden sie doppelt so viel Material verkaufen, weil sie können sie auch selber verdünnen, das kostet ja nichts, verkaufen sie doppelt so viel. Da dachte ich mir, ah gut, die wollen das kostensparend machen. Aber dann bin ich ihnen auf die Schliche gekommen, weil dann macht man nämlich diese ganze Spraydose voll und verwendet davon nur die Hälfte. Und dann denkst du dir, jetzt habe ich hier Bakterien rumstehen, die natürlich nach zwei Tagen keinen Bock mehr haben und sterben oder sich weiterentwickeln zu Lebewesen und musst du das wegkippen. Und schon denkst du dir, ah, haben die jetzt wirklich mein Interesse im Kopf oder nicht? Ich würde das da stehen lassen. Nee, nee, nee. Wieso Urzeitkrebsen beobachten?
Das geht auf.
Alles geht irgendwann auf.
Glaubst du, die Hefe ist so speziell?
Nee, alles geht auf.
Am Ende alle Bakterien, die gehen auf, alle Bakterien.
Was geht auf?
Ja, dann wachst du auf, dann hast du ja so eine ...
Wilde Kultur.
Ja, die fangen da an, die haben da ein Beinchen, und dann kommen die da rausgekrabbelt.
Erst mal Religion, erst mal so ein paar Stufen an der Situation. Nein, Stefan, erst Prostitution. Das älteste Gewerbe der Welt, wissen wir alle. Das heißt, einzeller, zweizeller Prostitution. Es ist einfach. Das kann dir jeder Biologe bestätigen. Vor dem ältesten Gewerbe muss es noch ein älteres Gewerbe gegeben haben. Sowas wie Essen zum Beispiel. Nein, nein, nein. Ich weiß nicht. Was heißt Gewerbe? Ich glaube, das ist eine Definitionsfrage. Aber dafür studieren andere Menschen, um das definieren zu können. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hätte ja gehofft, ein bisschen, dass ich noch euch durchs ganze Essen in Empfang nehmen Prozedere führen kann, aber das werden wir nicht mehr erleben, weil die noch ein bisschen länger brauchen. Aber spannend, mal einmal so mit, was hast du jetzt gemacht, du hast ein neues
Suzy-Restaurant ausgebaut. Ja, ich habe aber den Fehler
bemerkt, und zwar habe ich beim ersten
Restaurant die falsche Postleitzahl
angegeben, weil es gibt ja immer dieses
Auto-Fill-In, also du gibst dann
nur was ein und dann werden alle anderen
Felder auch automatisch ausgefüllt, wo, ich meine,
Google, hat ja nicht Google
jetzt diesen Rekord gebrochen, ich glaube,
1000 Milliarden, das ist dann eine Billion, oder? Die haben jetzt irgendeinen Marktwert erreicht. Ja, eine Billion der Börsenwerte. Moment, eine Milliarde sind tausend Millionen. Oder Millionen Millionen. Tausend Millionen. Und was ist eine Billion? Nochmal, das tausend Milliarden. Und die haben jetzt tausend Milliarden. Aber Google oder Amazon? Amazon war's. Jetzt auch Amazon. Nee, Apple. Apple und Amazon. Sind wir gerade in der Börsenrubrik? Ich hab den Jingle nicht gehört. Du hast damit angefangen. Wer die Börsenrubrik anfängt, muss auch den Jingle schreiben. So, und die haben so viel... Apple ist eine Billion US-Dollar wert. Und Amazon auch. So, und die haben so viel Geld und kriegen es nicht hin, dieses Autofill-Formular hinzukriegen. Bei mir ist es immer so, ich gebe dann die ersten Buchstaben meiner Adresse ein, zack, Adresse, und dann steht bei Firma, steht Herr. Und das muss ich immer rauslöschen, weil sonst denken die Firma Herr. Apple hat so viel Bargeldreserven, dass sie jedes Unternehmen der Welt kaufen könnten. Ist das nicht abgefahren? Jedes Unternehmen könnten die einfach sagen, ja, okay, Netflix, okay, Amazon, das war's, Disney. Total abgefahren. Aber die tun es nicht. Warum tun sie es nicht? Ich glaube, es ist eine Art Stille vor dem Sturm. Vor allem, die können doch jetzt einfach auch sagen, wir fliegen jetzt einfach zu Mars. Wir stinken jetzt einfach so viel in die Forschung, weil das ist ja auch so ein bisschen, ich habe mit einem Forscher, damals bei so einer Projektarbeit telefoniert, mit einem CERN-Wissenschaftler und den habe ich gefragt, warum wir nicht einfach zum Mars fliegen, da war ich noch sehr kleiner und das war meine erste Frage. Seine Antwort war, dass eine Zivilisation nicht bereit ist, so viel Geld auch aufzuwenden, es wäre ja ohne weiteres möglich, technisch. Und dann dachte ich, das ist doch komisch. Warum muss ein Planet Geld aufwenden für etwas, was ja ausserhalb der Welt nichts zählt? Aber das ist natürlich klar, weil eine Zivilisation funktioniert ja nur so. Die ist ja deswegen nur so weit technisch entwickelt, weil es halt sowas wie Geld gibt, zum Beispiel, was als Gegenwert zählt, damit die Zivilisation funktioniert. Und das fand ich ganz interessant. Und der hat mir gesagt, dass damals, als die Mayflower gestartet ist, nach Amerika, ähnlich viel Geld aufgebracht wurde von dieser Zivilisation, wie zum Beispiel wir jetzt müssten, um einen Kometen zu besiedeln. Einen Kometen? Einen Kometen zu besitzen. Ja, aber ballert der nicht vorbei?
Der ballert vorbei.
Aber das ist egal.
Der umkreist ja auch die Sonne.
Es umkreisen ja auch Kometen die Sonne.
Oder um in deinem Duktus zu bleiben, ballert um die Sonne.
Ja, aber sind es da nicht Planeten, wenn sie um die... Ja, okay, gut. Definitionsfrage.
Nein, gut ist auch kein Planeten.
Frebel ist so weit weg.
Frebi! Ich denke mir immer so bei diesen... Das fand so bei diesem, der größte Pfannkuchen der Welt, denke ich mir, gut, eine Idee, weil es eine Idee dieartet, größter Pfannkuchen der Welt, aber denk mal an Krebs. Lass mich dich mal in eine andere Richtung stoßen, Kollege. Könnte man nicht statt... Krebs der Welt? Nee, Krebs heilen. Dass man einfach sagt so, wir hatten die Entscheidung als Stadt Ulm, ja, wir können jetzt entweder den grössten Pfannkuchen der Welt backen, oder wir chippen so ein bisschen Krebs mal so von 40% auf 41%. Nee, wir haben uns für den Pfannkuchen entschieden. Aber man kann Krebs ja schon ganz gut besiegen, muss man schon sagen. Diese Chemo-Sachen sind schon abgefahren. Ich glaube, das grösste Problem ist vor allem, wie spät es entdeckt wird. Und da müsst ihr aufpassen, liebe Jungs da draußen, Hodenkrebs ist gefährlich. Immer die Hoden abtasten beim Duschen, jedes Mal, jeden Tag. Auch im öffentlichenchen, ganze Zeit, auch wenn ihr irgendwo in der Schule sitzt oder sowas, ist ja auch egal wo, einfach schön die Hand in die Hose und dann die Hoden abtasten nach Wölbungen. Und vor allem, Achtung, kleiner Tipp. Aber neben Hoden sind Wölbungen. Das ist ein bisschen problematisch. Ich bin sehr oft zum Arzt gerannt, bis er mir irgendwann gesagt hat, nein, Tietze, das sind Nebenhoden. Sie sollen schon zwei Hoden haben. Ach so. Das ist der Penis. Das muss da sein. Der muss da sein. Und jetzt gehen sie. Hausverbot. Zack, Hausverbot. Geht schnell beim Arzt. Denkt man gar nicht. Entweder abtasten oder, was ich auch mal gehört habe, die Maglite-Strategie.
Und zwar soll man sich breitbeinig hinstellen und dann von hinten mit einer Taschenlampe durch die Hoden durchleuchten, also dass man sich sozusagen ins Gesicht leuchtet und der Hoden ist dazwischen. Und dann, wenn man da dunkle Flecken sieht, dann ist man so gut wie tot. Und wenn die sich auch noch bewegen, dann war es das. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Neomagazinsitzung, wo ich unironisch zu dir gesagt habe, meine Hoden tun weh. Und du hast mir von diesem Tipp erzählt. Und ich fand das so toll. Und seitdem mache ich das wirklich, immer wenn mir langweilig ist, schön Taschenlampe vor den Hoden halten. Das ist ein Naturschauschen, Sondergleichen. Weil du hast ja nirgendwo an, du hast ja, es ist ja toll, durch Haut zu leuchten, durch was zu sehen, das macht ja Spaß, also Taschenlampe an sich machen ja auch schon Spaß, also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich habe grossen, grossen Spaß, mir Taschenlampe ins Gesicht zu halten und Gruselgeschichten zu erzählen, das sind ja unmenschliche Möglichkeiten, und da kann man so schön durchleuchten, das sieht ganz toll aus, also wirklich, ja, du hast mir das Leben gerettet, muss man auch sagen. Ich will nicht, ob man da was anderes durchleuchten kann. Aber alles andere ist wahrscheinlich zu dick, so ein Arm oder so ein Finger. Da sieht man auch noch nicht so viel. Apropos Krebsvorgang, ich bin ja jetzt bei der DKMS gemeldet. Ach ja, weil du immun bist gegen Aids. Weil ich immun bin gegen Aids und ich bin da jetzt schon seit mehreren Monaten angemeldet und ich dachte ja, klar, die werden mich sofort anrufen, die werden sofort sagen, wow, Herr Tietze, Wahnsinn, jemand wie Sie, den haben wir gebraucht in Deutschland, mit Ihnen können wir ganz Deutschland zunächst und dann die ganze Welt mit von Aids befreien. Kein Anruf, keine Mail, nichts, gar nichts. Und wenn es noch so ein paar Wochen so weitergeht, dass sie sich nicht melden, damit ich spende, ich will ja nicht operiert werden so gerne oder unter das Messer, aber trotzdem muss man das ja wahrscheinlich irgendwann. Und ich bin ja auch bereit, das Opfer zu geben, aber ich habe halt diese seltene Gabe der Aids-Resistenz, die ich in die Welt tragen will.
Aber wenn da jetzt nichts kommt, dann habe ich überlegt,
demnächst mal anzurufen und zu fragen, warum da niemand sich meldet bei mir. Das müssen wir aber machen,
wenn wir zusammen nebeneinander sind und aufnehmen.
Weil das ist wirklich
fast schon beleidigend so ein bisschen.
Das ist fast schon Blasphemie,
dass sie nicht anrufen mal und zumindest mal
nachfragen. Ja, ist schon, aber was muss man
heutzutage machen, um noch angerufen zu werden? Es reicht nicht mal, krebsimmun zu sein. Es reicht nicht, AIDS-resistent zu sein, naja, naja, naja. Was mache ich jetzt noch? Ich habe noch 40 Minuten bis zum Essen. Und ich weiß immer nicht, wie viele Sojasauce die dazu tun. Und ich denke mir immer, wahrscheinlich ist es zu wenig. Und es ist dann immer zu viel. Es sind immer sieben von diesen Päckchen. Vor allem, glaube ich, hast du mal gesagt, die beste Erfindung der Welt der Sojasoßenfisch. Oder irgendwoher kenne ich das? War das sogar so ein Comedian? Beste Erfindung Sojasoßenfisch? Von wem ist das? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich war das eigentlich. Tatsächlich finde ich immer interessant, viele Stäbchen, die mir beilegen. Und das ist immer ein guter Hinweis darauf, dass man keine vernünftige Ernährung hat. These, die legen ja immer zu viele bei. These, man bestellt jetzt Essen und kriegt drei Stäbchenpaare, dann isst man mit einem Paar. Die anderen beiden möchte man ja nicht wegwerfen, sondern man legt sie zur Seite in seine Besteckschublade. Und irgendwann öffnet man die Besteckschublade und sieht die und denkt sich, ach, ich hab ja noch Stäbchen, ich könnte ja mal wieder asiatisch bestellen. Doch, und plötzlich ist es wie eine Art Werbung, weil du denkst, ah, die hab ich ja noch, die müssen ja weg, also bestell ich, und dann kriegst du noch mehr. Die müssen ja weg. Stäbchenüberschuss, These, Geg, Gegenthese, Antithese, Sterbchenüberschuss führt nicht zu asiatischem Bestellen. Doch, wirklich, niemand hat es so drauf wie die Asiaten. Auch dieses, ah, die haben mir, ich habe manchmal so viel Glück, die haben mir zu viel Frühlingsrollen gegeben. Nein, du hängst an deren Angelhaken, mein Freund. Die wollen, dass du die in die Schublade steckst. Ja. Und dann irgendwann fällt dir auf, du hast ja noch Frühlingsrollen über, um dann Essen zu bestellen. Ich meine jetzt eher, dass man sich freut, weil man zu viel bekommt und denkt, ach, die sind so dumm, da bestelle ich nochmal, vielleicht schicken die mir aus Versehen eine Million Euro. Das stimmt. Ja. Neulich war ich auch asiatisch essen und haben die mir einen Glückskeks geschenkt und ich konnte das mein Glück nichtassen. Und ich habe mich wie ein Kind gefreut über diesen Glückskeks.
Warte, warte, sorry, ich kriege gerade einen anderen Anruf.
Das ist toll.
Hallo? Ah ja, guten Tag.
Ah, das kann sein, ich mache ihn auf.
Sekunde, und die Treppe hoch und dann rechts durch die Tür über den Gang.
Gut.
Ah, kein Trinkgeld.
Nein.
Nein. Ah, sind Trinkgeld! Nein!
Ah, sind 50 Cent zu wenig! Shit! Ich hab extra die grosse sind 50 Cent zu wenig. Ja, peinlich, dann lieber gar nichts. Ohne Scheiß, meine Regel unter 1,50, dann lieber gar nichts, alles andere ist peinlich.
Ist die spannendste Folge, die wir jemals aufgenommen haben.
Hört uns zu, wie wir crazy Aktionen machen, wie Essen bestellen oder den Lieferboten annehmen oder Trinkgeld besorgen oder Essen auspacken. Die Podcast-Sufo, Abenteuergarantie. Ah, das ist viel zu viel, das ist viel zu viel. So. So, Moment. Habe ich dich jetzt noch, Stefan? Stefan? 22 Minuten steht es hier noch bei mir auf der Uhr. Stefan, wir können direkt loslegen, wir können zusammen essen, mehr oder weniger. Mega gut und vor allem, was ist passiert? Genau das, was eigentlich nicht passieren sollte, da stand ja Hinweis an das Restaurant und ich habe geschrieben Treppe hoch und dann rechts durch. Und genau das hat er nicht gemacht. Warum schreibt man das überhaupt rein? Nee, er ist einfach die Treppe ganz hoch gegangen. Links durch? Wahnsinn, wenn du jetzt eine gefährliche Lebensmittelallergie hättest. Ich bin so froh, dass ich noch ein zwei Euro Stück gefunden habe. Ich hatte nur 50 Centstücke und ich denke mir so, du kannst ja dann auch nicht vier 50 Centstücke geben oder zehn oder sowas. Was? Weißt du, was ich gerade gegeben habe? Ich hätte nämlich auch nichts mehr. Ich habe acht zwanzig Centstücke gegeben. Was? Ach, das ist, nee, das ist demütigend. Der muss den ganzen Abend jetzt mit dem ganzen Kleingeld ballen, hast du die Gegend auf. Nee, Stefan, nee, den rufst du nochmal zurück. Aber sein Dankeschön war übertrieben. Es war ein, oh, Dankeschön. Ja, ironisch nennt man das. Nein! Doch! Das war nicht ironisch. Klar war das ironisch. Ja klar, wenn dir jemand irgendwie 20 Münze in die Hand gibt, dann sagst du, oh, Dankeschön, Herr Tietze, vielen Dank! Für manche ist es auch noch Geld. Für manche ist es auch noch Geld, Florian, für dich. Die Arbeit von so einem Liefertyp, dessen Arbeit ist Mobilität, der kann nicht so viel Ballast bei sich haben. Der wirft das in Müll. Der wirft das hinter sich immer ab, wie so jemand, der mit einem heißen Ballon fliegt, der so hinter sich das Geld rauswirft. Aber die Lektion, ich habe auch wieder viel zu viel. Also durch diese scheiß Mindestbestellung haut man sich halt dann so viel in den Warenkorb. Aber ganz kurz, du bestellst Sushi und du landest nicht bei 15 Euro? Das ist aber meine leichteste Übung. Also, ich bin so locker immer bei 20 Euro beim Sushi. Nee, nee, aber ich kann ja keine Sets nehmen, weil es in der Regel nie vegane Sets gibt. Das heißt, ich muss mir immer dann so fünf von denen, fünf von denen und da kommt man tatsächlich recht günstig weg und am Ende nimmt man halt dann, okay, noch mal fünf, noch mal fünf, noch mal fünf, noch mal fünf, um auf 20 zu kommen und dann noch so so eine schöne Suppe zu verspeisen. Also ich bin bedient. Ich werde die ganze Nacht durchsetzen. Ich wünsche dir einen guten Appetit. Du, Stefan, das wünsche ich dir auch. Mit dem guten Appetit verabschieden wir uns auch in die Woche und auch in die Sommerpause, denn wir sind jetzt erst mal zwei Wochen nicht da. Was? Was? Warum? Ich bin im Urlaub. Ich bin im Urlaub. Habe ich dir doch schon geschrieben. Ich hätte noch keinen Urlaub. Du schreibst so viel Quatsch, immer mit deinen ganzen Gifs und deinen ganzen Newslettern, weißt du, aber da kann man nicht einfach auf Newsletter abbestellen klicken, nein, da hat man halt die Weihnachtskarte und die Osterkarte und die Pfingstkarte von dir. Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich bin jetzt erst mal schön im Urlaub, zwei Wochen lang, viel Spaß, und danach geht's direkt weiter mit unserer ersten Live-Show in Mannheim, das heißt, die nächste Folge, die ihr hören werdet, eins,, 146, ist schon die Live-Show. Ansonsten viel Spaß dabei, ihr könnt ja auch noch Karten kaufen, falls ihr noch keine habt für die folgenden Shows. Jetzt geht die Tour los. Ab jetzt geht die Tour los. Nach dieser Folge ist offiziell die Tour. Und es gibt noch Karten. Es gibt noch ein paar Karten. Es gibt noch ein paar Karten. Also greift zu, werdet ihr noch keine habt. Tolles Geschenk, auch zu Weihnachten. Kommt vorbei. Vielen Dank an Richard für das Intro, für diese Folge. Fantastisch.
Mega-Into. Fantastisches Intro.
Und vielen Dank, schöne Wochen und seht uns, wenn ihr Bock habt.
Ansonsten macht's gut, wir heben ab, guten Appetit, Stefan, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Dir auch, ciao, ciao!